convierte 10 elevado a las 2 igual a 100
en una ecuación logarítmica y bueno lo
que quiero que le hace aquí es que
tenemos a 10 elevado a la potencia de 2
de que ponerlo aquí 10 elevado a la
potencia 2 me da 100 eso lo sabemos
bastante bien ahora lo que quiero hacer
es convertirlo en una ecuación
logarítmica y cuando nosotros pensamos
en una cuestión logarítmica básicamente
lo que estamos diciendo es como lo
inverso lo que voy a decir es 10 cuando
lo elevó a qué potencia me va a dar 100
10 elevado a qué potencia me da 100 y es
justo aquí cuando utilizamos la palabra
el logaritmo y bueno aquí el 10 me quedó
un poco grande así que déjenme a borrar
esta palabra y pegarla un poquito más el
logaritmo en base 10 de 100 es decir a
qué potencia tenemos que elevar el 10
para que nos dé 100
esto es igual a y la respuesta pues es 2
logaritmo en base 10 de 100 es igual a 2
porque 10 elevado al cuadrado
es igual a 100 estas dos ecuaciones son
exactamente lo mismo estoy hablando del
mismo lenguaje 10 elevado a la 2 igual a
100 estoy pensándolo en un lenguaje
exponencial mientras que si digo que el
logaritmo en base 10 de 100 igualados
estoy hablando no en un lenguaje
logarítmico sin embargo las dos
representan la misma idea y bueno pues
entramos un poco en terminología vamos a
ponerle nombres este 10 que tengo aquí
es la base la base de mi logaritmo la
base del exponente este 2 y este 2 estos
que tengo aquí son mi potencia o mi
exponente entonces voy a ponerle el
exponente y el 100 pues es mi resultado
o la respuesta después de aplicar la
potencia y bueno estas dos expresiones
son la misma verdad sobre pensar que 10
elevado al cuadrado es igual a 100 así
que nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo